Here, you can see the declaration of the scanner. Here, we are reading an
integer. Here, we are reading a decimal number. And before we read anything, we
have a prompt. One prompt for the age, one prompt for the weight. Finally,
there is an important piece that you've not seen so far, look up here. This is
what's called an import statement. As it happens, the scanner class is in a
different location than the classes that you've used so far. That location is
called java.util, it's a utility class, and we have to tell the compiler that's
the place to find it. Whenever you use the scanner, simply place this statement
at the top of your code. Let's go ahead and run this. The console window pops
up. Here is my prompt. Okay. I'm going to lie about my age here. Now, if that
had been my age of course the program would be right next here. I'd be 22. Not
much one can do about one's age. It does increase every year. And I lie about
my weight too. But I appreciate the sentiment that hopefully next year, it'll
be less. That at least should be under my control. All right. Now, you've seen
how to read input, and I'd like you to do it in another program. Remember this
program, in which we added the sunset effect to a photo. Now here, we used a
value of 25 to increase the redness. It might be nice to experiment with other
numbers. But instead of recompiling the program with all sorts of different
numbers, let's turn this one into a user input. Now, we can't put the input
statement here. Because this method is called for every single pixel, and we
only want to supply the input once. So, here's the plan. Take out this
constant, and add a parameter here. Then here, in the main method, prompt and
read the input here before entering this piece of code. by the way, don't worry
about this loop statement here. We're going to be covering that in a couple of
lessons. Now, here is the place that the method is called. That's where you
should pass the added red variable, so that each time the redden method adds
that amount of red. Go ahead and do that now. If you have BlueJ, it would be
best if you first develop the program in BlueJ, and then when you're done, put
your result into the Udacity IDE. If you don't have BlueJ, that's okay, just do
it straight in the IDE. But then you won't be able to supply your own input.
You'll have to live with the input that Udacity gives you.